welcome to the recruitment rollercoaster
podcast my name is Hisham azuz
today I am in sunny Bristol and I'm your
boy from Brittany born and bred
born and bred and I'm joined by Jack
Cole on my left and Tom Hurley who's in
front of me and who are both the
founders of a recruitment business
called method resourcing hashtag follow
the method I just took follow the method
thanks for joining me guys and thanks
for having us
excites hours a century before I haven't
had I haven't done this with two other
people for a while we should put some
new kit yeah this is exciting so
obviously we are gonna spend quite a bit
of time talking about your journey so
far in starting your own recruitment
business but where I always like to
start is how the hell did both of you
end up in the world of recruitment I
start there okay first in short never
had the intention of getting into
recruitment wanted to be a police
officer
really yeah originally was to be a
police officer but basically didn't want
to go in at like the age of 18 years old
and want to get a bit of life experience
so like most people ended up working in
cells doing door-to-door sales
absolutely hated it for like this
Lucetta gas-electric oh wow they're
covered door to door door to door I mean
that's grim Scotch the southern energy
well it was all character building I
mean I was quite like a shy individual
at that time and I didn't think cells
was gonna work for me well no first six
months absolutely hated it but then kind
of got in a groove and started to enjoy
it and then started to make some decent
money and I was made redundant which
kind of fell a really convenient time
because I was actually looking to leave
after about 18 months but you did door
to door for 18 months yeah My Fair Play
mate that's a long time that mate yeah
yeah I think that's like a life sentence
for daughter garden that's like you end
up in those like weird pyramid schemes
then yeah yeah I actually had a basic
salary already 12,000 pounds of yeah
yeah rolling in it 14 mate that's a lot
of money in it yeah
do you feel like that that definitely
had gave you light of good grounding
yeah it was pecan he's good confidence
boost
you know and how did I just overcome
objection and actually taught me to be
like an opportunist hmm sounds like
really strange but like if it was
raining instead of sat in the it's being
sat in the car mmm way in like photos
like the rain to call off I'll just
stick myself out in the rain so I'm
still not a Dorset people then go oh
young like 17 year old yeah and where
let's bring him inside as soon as I was
in the house and I'm in a position where
I can then just have like a deeper
conversation yeah nine times out of ten
I then and that like I actually just
signed them up sir I think that like it
was the early years just being able to
like you know being opportunist and then
like capitalize on it I think when you
get into sales as well I think is for me
once you're in sales and yeah actually
give it a good old crack I could never
now be in a job where Dave next to me
does the same job and it's not sales and
I we get paid the same but he's
half-assed in there andand you know I
mean dude yes that's like being able to
actually like earn what you put in then
I once I experienced as well as Nam Dinh
a job that isn't sales yeah I mean yeah
so yeah basically we went from doing
that got made redundant walked into
office angels the get ourselves job than
they were advertising at the time and
then walked out with job in recruitment
soldier the dream yeah pretty much
what about you Tom I actually got
declined the job office Angels did you
which is probably an embarrassing fact
but you know just part of my part of my
my recruitment journey journey I saw one
yeah but I was like most I did a degree
and sports coaching absolutely shocked
and yeah I didn't know what I was gonna
do was gonna go in to teach a neutral
kind of stuff and actually my my wife
who was my girlfriend at the time her
her flatmates boyfriend worked for
office angels and he said when you go
for an interview office Angels so
Rockets up in a pair sandals
sans shorts and a t-shirt like I said
like a typical student basically laughed
at the last other room
well you leave she walked in their life
everybody job pretty pretty much yeah
pretty much there obviously didn't get a
job there and then I interviewed with
progressive and Bristol and g2 mmm and
yeah stop working 42 14 years ago but
I'm assuming obviously what I know about
the only definite
thing doe then sandals absolutely not
yeah you'd have got loft out absolutely
yeah okay so for both you them what was
your perception of recruitment at that
point of interest I was interested I
didn't really I think we have one no
because I think like like I suppose when
you hear about recruitment initially it
sort of by like money and fast cars and
all that kind of stuff but that
particular time for me was just I just
needed a job
hmm and like it was the first job I got
offered and it was until I actually got
into the industry that I start to really
understand what it was about
mm-hm and how difficult it was but
obviously the rewards you can get from
it okay did you have a what was your
bedroom to be fair the guys are seniors
were like really good it just like set
the boundaries the expectation of what
the role was all about because I
initially gone in for something
completely different
yeah it was like a real education piece
and I as she was like yeah I like the
manager you know I bought into him and
like the way he just sold it to me I was
like yeah just just make sense to go and
do that I like the fact there was you
know really sells focused and it wasn't
kind of like the administrative hey char
so things which sometimes like
recruitment can't get perceived yeah so
how long have you both been in
recruitment now since then it's my 14th
year fourteenth year yeah nine years now
yeah yes no time that there's a long
time time so I guess what I always like
sorts of people about because it
definitely is one of the most
challenging parts of getting this
recruitment is your first 12 months so
just to set the scene with did you go
into a perm or con like so yeah I was
looking I office angels it was like yeah
what about you Tom was it contract part
yeah I did perm for 18 months and I
flipped over to contract for what at 11
yeah half years cost back through first
year then talked a bit about that was it
challenging for you how was the first 12
months I tell you it was like a
completely different type of recruitment
and what we obviously do now but I think
there's some really good lessons there
because I offers angels you recruit him
for office managers secretaries piays
customer service cells yeah there's so
many different I guess like verticals it
was trying to go for it sought you out
like recruit like really quickly cause
all these different areas but
I didn't give you as then like the
candidate relationship management
because you can never use that conduct
really more than say like twice yeah so
what it taught me was just like you know
working a job with that pace with that
urgency and hopefully then kind of how
did you do but it was alright I've done
150 grand in my first year which isn't
bad but it was a fairly warm desk in
Bristol which had been worked by like
you know million Collins previously so I
was a good candidate for good client
pool yeah it was it was more of a case
of like just like putting the placement
into the businesses already there so it
was a really kind of like proper
equipment and I say that like the time
actually become like a proper cruise
when I just joined dopost which was like
18 months later fair enough
how about you tell me how your first I
was tough I was really tough yeah so so
I walked into g2 I think is like the
fourth or fifth member
oh wow you walking into an office right
you've got James golf and Simon Gillings
who are probably some of the top bidders
s3 progressive of ever seen Charlie
Walker doing half a million quid a year
one contract is a bit of pretty daunting
thing but tough but like I learned a
hell of a lot really hell of a lot yeah
what was challenging about that first
year you just go through like real
emotions don't you like you know you can
have like a real high and a real low and
can change by the hour and I think what
I learned though is is ultimately like
you've got me super positive
yeah like hard work for me was that was
the thing that got me through my first
year really yeah definitely work ethic I
just figured yeah like you know it's
quite old school but I think if you were
to back in my early days I used to think
if I worked harder than a person to the
right or left me I put myself in a
position to potentially give myself more
opportunities hmm which has probably
changed a little bit now but I think for
me that was that was that was how I kind
of attack my first year then what just
around that just quickly just because I
think a lot of people listening maybe
around that part and I think I always
get message around people saying like ah
how can I get better at managing those
yeah but good time bad time I'm sure see
now you having your own business yeah
and more so but absolutely anything that
you got better on that first year I
think like if you're having self times
in your 30 you just got to talk to
people yeah because everyone goes
through it there's no I've not met
anyone in my 14 years in recruitment of
corny yeah it's been a blast for 14
years I've never had
I've never found it difficult so then
you've got to talk to the people around
you yeah you know seek advice and I
think in hindsight now like don't be too
hard on yourself in the first 12 months
yeah because you think it's the worst
thing in the world if you don't put a
job or you don't know that's true hit
your target whatever maybe but actually
it's not if you just break things down
like I used to obsess our metrics really
know you know for some people you know
metrics on in recruitment I'm a big
believer that they are but for me that
was a big thing I stir what's really
worked out what you had to do on a daily
basis absolutely yeah
well I think because when you first go
out and you're first at three six months
if you're if all your purely thinking
about it's right deal deal deal deal
you're gonna get this on very very
quickly I used to try and think and I
used to get my guys and Jack the sukkah
to say my trainees is to think about
right watch activity I need to do in
order to get to that point where I get
my first interview or pull my first job
- they're not amel get to your first
place they're just as good with us to
celebrate absolute you know I mean
absolutely you gotta celebrate small
wins otherwise you your brain you know
internally combusts don't you being
being around those big pillars then
earlier yeah how much do you learned how
much do you think they impacted you in
those four like a lot really but they
were all so different really that's been
very very different yeah all very very
different and I think I'm sure jack will
agree over the years you've you
surrounded by different like big billers
that of all with different backgrounds
some have done masters at Oxford some of
yeah you know and then different
approaches absolutely yeah yeah and I
think if you can take a little bit from
each one of those and kind of you know
people will recruit in different ways
but they have equality yeah I think it's
like yeah beer Spartans Fink well that
look at what they're doing and then sort
of tell you what you like yeah and put
your own spin on things but I think
that's really good advice like if you're
listening right now and you are
struggling this like one or you speak
and send on around you it's not a bad
thing it's not a bad thing to just say
look I'm struggling this bar like any
how absolutely and also who you learning
from as well yes first 12 months and
okay
so just to set the scene then Jack for
you see what sort of courses your grand
and office angel start there anywhere to
no purpose for how long nearly six years
over six years nor today they was their
HQ in Bristol that's yes an original
Bristol yeah basic renowned brand in
Bristol isn't that so six years yeah and
then left there and then joined and then
start messing yeah yeah and then Tom
just everyone listening so join g2 quite
early on yeah so what are they now
they're huge
yeah GTV yeah they're absolutely like
they're for fire
well I was a fourth I was a fourth or at
g2 or the fifth fire and then Charlie
Walker set up vivid which was an
offshoot of g2 okay at the GTV group and
I went to London with him so how kind of
scale and run that office in London for
was that for all the time yeah yeah so
it's something the same group a lot of
businesses will spin-off businesses yeah
that is meant with that because yeah
I've got a bit of context around g2 but
my mum who is that I met but their
London office part of it is g2 and part
of it is vivid yeah and they'd like
Doric completely yeah well they're in
they're in the same office block but in
different rooms yeah you know you'd go
up against like you'd go up against you
know someone that you know and as long
as it was healthy healthy competition
yeah sometimes Helton's yeah now as
their first there for ten years so I was
a GTV group top billers been with top
builder and then find it quite difficult
getting into management to start off
with it yeah like you tend to
concentrate on yourself don't you and
yeah you first get into sales so work
that so you ended up there Tennant and
after that you then settlement yeah
moved back to Bristol with my wife and
kids suck it and work for Opus for two
and a half years how are we John - Rhett
- they're like learn loads they're a
great business and then yeah the
opportunities you know came to set up on
my own and Jack is a co-founder yeah
that was 18 months ago 18 months we were
cool so let's just talk a bit about that
sort of juggling up to that point yeah
so just to help me out so both of you
did you go down the typical light Billa
senior consult and then you're managing
a few people did you both do that yeah
so joint iopa training recruiting we
know that like 18 months experience but
never done like IC recruitment and like
my first six months were probably the
hardest cuz I was trying to recruit in
the way that I do and actually I kind of
had to just like go in reinvent myself
completely from scratch again and just
kind of restart my work
recruitment career so my first six
months was actually I really tough at
you don't like one placement really I
still recall to this day like my manager
like six months pretty much on the dot
I'm said though you got do like three
deals today pretty much said to him I
was just like you know what I'd do that
I actually then done three deals that
day really done like eight and nine
deals that month and then want a ski
trip to a shaman a for like the last
slots master and then like you know
never turn back yeah so that but in
terms of the like the progression it was
like start there there any yeah so and
senior principal team lead and then was
where to manager we had like 32 people
working for me
32 yeah and then Tom just really similar
right yeah so start officer as a
recruiter and then work myself up to
team leader in sales manager yeah but
it's funny I think like that progression
you can really identify what you're good
at and what you're as the chose so quit
1 definitely keen sort of unwrapped
laughing that there's so many things in
there that you could probably give a lot
of value around for people listening
just on that point jack that you just
sayin I think if you think obviously I'm
sure you've experienced it now like what
would your wife speeds and people that
are listening that maybe have made a
move recently or considering a move
because you hear all the time where I'm
a recruit to have two years I'm about
going to another recruitment business
and I feel like I know how to do
recruitment so I think also you have to
have some real humility there to be like
had to reinvent yourself to go I mean I
think what what did you sort of learn
around that that I think a lot of people
will go through that I'm sure you may
have experienced it now where you hire a
recruit and then play are now to do
recruitment yes like what have you
learned what how did you get better at
that or how did you at first I was like
a proud person I did really ask for the
help because I was going in with a bit
of experience and I didn't want to ask
for the help but I soon realized that
actually if I didn't then it was just
yeah basically so is it just that is
that hanging there it was just a bit of
a realization of what what I've been
taught what happened it isn't working
yeah I think it was bit of like self
reflection really really like
like it's not working as for help and
then I just started asking for more help
then side identify like the areas where
I'm doing really well in Mebane like it
was just really really minor tweaks and
changes that then just took my eyes up
of just doing things slightly
differently being a little bit more
assertive with certain things I was
doing and as a result you know it deals
that stuff through why didn't you why
didn't you quit in those six months a
lot people - really yeah quite like
self-critical of like yeah not failing
um had a point to prove
yeah basically fair enough yeah why is
that point Jack okay then and then the
markets use it was it IT but tech call
yeah yeah well cuz we were quite small
when I when I joined g2 I've basically
mopped up any permit was given to me
really yes it was one day would be like
a mechanical engineer the next it would
be something else but it wasn't till I
went into contract myself I actually
built mine built my own desk and did it
properly really really yeah and then and
then help me out Jack to them did you
basically the journey I hope is
reviewable in lobby like this basically
or yeah I mean someone done it very
briefly for a period of time so um I
even though I was based in Bristol
accruing in the London market had done
it for a very brief period of time done
a write on it but I kind of pill Billy
pretty much from scratch really yeah so
let's just talk a bit about that that
period of you obviously know you've had
to do quite a bit of that method now but
I guess again one of the most sort of
common things that I get asked about is
business development winning new
business these sorts of things I guess
you can talk about it now and have your
patient now but I guess what what what's
your been your experience or what your
thoughts on how people should be
approaching new business or the things
that you've learned along the way there
were probably a lot of people fall short
on I think for me what I did was open
certain ly and I still kind of
encouraged people to do that like now
it's like first four weeks you just want
to buy yourself into speech there's many
candidates using and contract and perm
because you need to know what a good
contract CV looks like versus a good
purpose
so that if you're in a conversation with
the manager you're able to say actually
the skill say you liked him before lends
itself as a three-four in Japan today
contractors know the poem salary of 40
grand for example so and then that way
you can obviously just you know build up
what knowledge you've got on the market
I think knowledge is key at the end of
the day they got knowledge you got power
and then you can actually sell off the
back of it the best recruiters I've ever
worked with those the people that like
know that market like the back of their
hand really yeah
well I think you've got you've got like
you fundamentally to build if you want
to be a big villa you have to build a
market you have to know your market
otherwise you just spread yourself too
thin you're trying to do too many too
many different things at once and
ultimately I must my purse I just don't
think that's scalable really what did
you ended up in Asia and so I did buy
the business intelligence and data
warehousing initially yeah we double
down on them yeah just uh but yeah and
it wasn't until perhaps as I got a
little bit more experienced there I mean
we were classic contract builder we
would new might be I marketing there was
a market very well but you know we would
land and expand excuse a cliche with a
client and you know network around the
different hiring managers get to know
the re managers so you know my contract
but towards the end of my sort of tenure
at Vivid was a real mixture of you know
testers devs project managers and it was
a lot of the business was relationship
that really and I think that's a thing
that people need to do now and if you
can again go to a good market in
businesses you have to have key
relationships and we're key stakeholders
hmm and I think that's something we've
developed massively since we saw a
method is not just about it's about spin
your your business develop development
between like your reactive and you're
proactive lists you know your reactive
quick wins but also having you know
forging long long term relationships and
managers attending events running your
own events and making sure you've got
you know parallel relationships how do
you in your opinion on how how do you
measure if you look good relation to
some one that's a good question know the
names of our kids kids but we took my
yesterday I think it's how it may be you
can't measure it this way but I think
when you're having
unworked related conversations before
you get into work-related conversations
is a really good measure of how that
person actually knows you
yeah so some of the best people that
Jack and I have and I've worked with you
know we'll go and meet him for a beer
and have a chat about non work stuff for
a good hour before we actually talk
about you know the nitty-gritty of I
think that's a good thing to think about
and how many how much business we've got
when you're thinking long term and stuff
it's like it's good good things to think
about right is this is this going on the
right track
yeah my Cuban did you know I'm in and
this is where like you've got to be
smart when you think about metrics and
conversations in history but I made a
hundred calls today like that's that's
not what we're referring to like it's
about having a good balance between
quality conversations they're gonna lead
to okay only like you know business and
and also about I've been identifying you
know is this is this something you know
what you don't want to do is sort piss
off a manager or can they're really
really quickly when actually over time
you can forge something that is you know
more long-term yeah so did a service to
our nation no it's funny you can say you
can throw on him a good problem so then
can did even become managers because you
build what a big director might after
many weeks yeah maturity I was like I
always want to be a manager because I
assumed that director because I assumed
that that was the best job though yeah
actually I am a fraction like you know
being a manager in recruitment
especially a billion managers like it's
fundamentally the hardest job sorry okay
like most recruiters I know are actually
quite selfish individuals yeah cool
and like that just because you're a good
bit it doesn't mean you're gonna be a
good manager yeah and like I was a good
bitter so I assumed I was going to be a
good manager and in actual fact my first
like year as a team lead was probably
pretty crap to be fair
why was he bad because I was just I got
hired like cardboard copies of myself
and sure you'd always want to assume
that everyone would basically just
follow suit so and I would do but
actually that's not the way the
management really works it was until we
actually had like proper leadership
training that I actually then like sat
back and realized crap like yeah I've
been doing this wrong for like such
long period of time and then like you
know just changing a few things I like
big the big one for me was actually like
learning how people learn okay like I'm
learning starts question now yeah and
then they kind of think give you a get
gave you a gauge of like how they people
like to learn and then like the output
of that that's like so the big learning
for you was actually yeah understanding
how people best learn and then that
means you can deliver the training a web
and in the way they see yeah yeah that's
interesting because how many people know
the best way that they learn are I
definitely it's like my thing now really
yeah because like I saw like you know
going from being like fairly average you
know Billings for my team's like
actually you know some pretty
significant results off the back of it
so it's actually something that like
I've just taken many times but it's
great for picking Marcus as well because
you've got some people that learn you
know I'd like to fail when they do
things and they learn that well people
that like to plan you know in putting
someone on a contract or permanent
market different personality suit
different markets yeah it was a great
way to understand how you can develop
and self-analysis yourself as well like
I'm a pragmatic how was it pragmatic
[Music]
[Laughter]
really good tangible advice I guess for
you Tom did you so for you did you again
have the same sort of perception as far
as a manager means more money
responsibility that's yeah yeah I mean
as a young recruiter you know I think my
motivations initially was just about
recognition really yeah definitely and
definitely about you know having a good
job title you know earning as much money
as you can all the fickle stuff that
actually now isn't that really important
to me yeah as a young recruit so of
course you wanted to be a team leader
and a manager really quickly because I'm
a team leader or a manager but of course
by Jack said I think that the thing I
thing I find the most difficult for me
was just you have to be I was quite a
selfish recruiter initially in my early
years and you have to think about the
people and actually what someone working
for
you've gotta look after them you've got
to train them you've got to develop them
and I think it's really important that
you know if you're going through that
process now if anyone's listen is that
you know having two people working
together with each other it's a lot more
effective if you're targeting clients
than just one person it's you know like
a you know tunnel vision like yeah it'll
still still still how did you actually
start changing that there like that cuz
that must've been a process I loads
people that didn't want to work for me
that left you know was stuff that you
think you know I got to change what I'm
doing yeah so I kind of I kind of found
my own way of doing things over time I
wasn't I didn't have the fortunate
training that Jack bit in terms of you
know learning the girls questionnaires
and stuff it was the you know I wasn't
retaining staff as a trainee - trainee
manager mmm anyway I actually started
reflecting right what am i doing why
would would I want to work for myself if
I was a trainee and then I started
thinking actually no that's like a good
question to ask yourself isn't that
great thing that Oprah's done they sent
how like anonymous like surveys done by
like other directors other managers in
the business in the business of like
what their perception was of me really
then like there's some good stuff in
there but there was like some like
pretty big areas of improvement really
it was a sobering thought I got told it
like a geography teacher okay so bring
thought of like actually nowhere near as
good as like I think I am like I'm miles
away from where I want to be and like if
I want to become a director I need to
change like all of these things about
myself so like yeah just like I guess
like if you if you're running a business
maybe like that's a good thing to do
mm-hmm okay so and so that was you Tom
you mentioned obviously you was one of
the top pillars yeah brand why do you
think that is why do I think that is the
best I start I just stuck at it what was
your best year about four eight nine and
that was in that was in UK IT so I think
if you look at some of the International
stuff now I think you know
and ask for the big money is yeah I
thought you was up that would have been
too would have been out 2019 so that
would have probably been 2012 yeah 2013
mm-hm
but I think I just I just stuck at it
like but it sounds silly but I didn't
have any other options
no I did it I could did a university
degree and it was it was an all right
and I had a good time at uni but you
know I wasn't gonna go and work yeah
what's the Hennessy or be a doctor yeah
I you know I didn't have a choice and I
just and I you know and I had a pot that
like had a point to prove so I just got
on with it and I think like you know
you've got that was that what that was
my thing and I saw you went through a
lot of lows you know and suddenly you
start seeing the money and it's becomes
more comfortable and you start learning
the job and then it becomes second
nature really what do you do was there
many so I think we'll see what's
interest in females obviously quite
early on you got sort of exposure to
some people that oxy here in some big
years yeah so I think a lot of lot of
the questions I get or people sent
message me sent messages to me is Hisham
on that there's sort of 200 mark or 150
mark contracted something to came on
yeah 250
how come I want some advice on breaking
that much you know I mean so yeah
was that quite in your sort of fall was
quite normal to hit those sort of
numbers absolutely yeah yeah yeah I mean
I must be such so those those figures
now if you look at the GTV group now me
they're doing six seven eight nine nine
undercut that the way my advice to those
people is always bring on your business
always bring them always always bring on
you boss what's the stat you like your
starts tracking you lose 14 percent if
your book there we go year-on-year
unless you think oh yeah you just got
bring on your businesses because you
know you can you've got 35 contractors
you like yeah great job done you know
okay coming late 40 50 grand a month
suddenly you sending your contractors go
and you stop bringing your managers
again they're like well we're not hiring
you've just filled all the positions
you've got so God bring one God bring on
users if you experience a big Jam than
in Billings or was it was it a little
quieter increase for that year no it's
just relatively no I wasn't like there
wasn't one thing that I in particularly
that really I did that it was just a
concert a contribution of just of just
hard graft really mm-hmm
how about you Joe was your best year me
my bestie was actually wanted like
method realist yeah yeah
miss bansidhar like that's impressive so
what was the first year what do you do
first year like pretty much since like
my first full year in opus it's been a
bit of in-between like 200 250 I've been
pretty consistent so I've never done
like the figures at Tom's done there's
always a perm accrued so up until pretty
much like doing some contract stuff with
with method here so yeah for like the
last like seven ish well eight years
really it's been pretty much like 200
250 I think best is about like 270
really so you've done that method yeah
that's not bad at that that's not too
bad but that was contract down pay yeah
more more being some of the sort of
learnings for you there may in your
experience in I bet again I think the
obviously you say there's numbers n not
copies tom bit like consistently hitting
there's number that's that decent you
want me to consistently hit those types
of numbers yeah some of the key things
for you that you think have impacted
that or contributed to that I think it's
just like the mix of like your activity
around reactive in like proactive
business and just like not like just sat
there thinking you've you've made it
because you've had one year yes then
you've done like 200 grand and you've
got your accounts because like your
accounts are soon dry up things can
change like the you know the wind like
our top three clients from last year not
not hired this year that's really
interesting I've got a single placement
with them now if we just sat on that
like again it was about 280 K of our
first year's GP they none of them have
hired this year that's crazy
yeah and we're what we are eight months
into the year we do June to Juden so
yeah I'd like for me interest yeah I
just always make sure I get out at least
like once or twice month down to London
me as many candidates as possible just
make sure you've got good mix of like
reactive and proactive like business
development and it's a clarify for
people listen and what what you deem as
reactive approach to so reactive being
like you've got an interview lead direct
up for something you're chasing down
that it like someone's hiring now yeah
I've got if you're chasing your tail a
little bit for that
proactive being you know you know that
they hire you know they like you might
be trouble and he's gonna take you
potentially three six twelve months for
no I've been dressed on cuz again quite
a few people asked me this light what
did what did your day look like when he
was been in that sort money mate it was
a pretty militant yeah yes when I sat in
that office on my own literally with no
clients no candidates an empty database
I went back to the same day plan I had
when I start to accrue what was the day
plan they talk to me right so I get in
the morning and I would call all my hot
leads all my managers pre nine o'clock
yeah because of course they were all
arriving and yeah looking at BBC Sport
having a chitchat they go to meetings at
9:00 we're trying to get all that done
really early I then do my reactive
manager list probably between 10:00 and
11:00 so that would be like a target
client I'd wanted to get into you know
messages to LinkedIn all that kind of
stuff and then I'd lead gen hopefully no
candidates are listening I lead gen them
for a couple of hours talking to
candidates my candidates that I know
what's getting on the mark here yeah
then I would again go back to probably
chasing those leads between 10 M 10 one
hammer lunch and then I'd repeat in the
afternoon yeah which is pretty boring by
you know I for me again it was just I
like routine and I think yeah that's how
I learn was some routine because I knew
why I was against my target or what I
was I was you worked out if you did that
and you know had X amount of
conversation that's just that's just how
I did it I'm not saying it's right for
everybody but for a lot of people are
interested in yeah a lot of people don't
touch their day because there's a
contract and so on right you know you
might lordy you might have put your
first job for three months so how do you
know if you're improving you know again
in my opinion how do you know if you're
improving in the first three months if
you've got no way of measuring it and I
you know I think it's very very
difficult to do hmm
have both of you always want to start
your own business not it was only
probably the the second half of my my 7
to 14 years and recruitment why I wanted
to yeah really I just having seen having
seen other people that I thought I was
as good at this good ass doing it I
thought yes what's easy yeah give it a
go yeah make loads of money yes he's a
PC but it's not about you jack
they're like you always liked the idea
of running your own business because
when you're younger you just assume like
when you're in business you've got more
money in everyone else that's just like
a maturity thing again maybe because I
grew up in please don't say job yeah I
think it was like when I become like a
manager and then like you know becoming
much better like managing people people
buying into me I still billing billing
get money and yeah it's just like you
just want to do so for yourself
sometimes then you how did you two meet
opus yeah or do you know you know about
this yeah when I move out from when I do
back from you I see your you live in
Eastbourne but you have a London Eye
that's like you know it's like in London
you've got these like wicked pubs and
restaurants and you go out really ice
drinks after work
well I joined Opus and they're their
local wasn't there was an Italian
restaurant and I'd only been there for a
week so I thought I know I'll go and
meet everyone and you know yeah get to
know everyone real make an effort so I
wasn't Italian at first I was bit of
snob I thought this way what is this
place yes and these guys had all been on
lunch Club so I'm at the bar like Norman
no mate somewhere and I introduced
myself to everyone and then the big oaf
jacker eyes biomes comes bounding in
like there's like the sea parts and he
comes flying through hugs me gives me
this big smooch on the cheek I know I
thought myself like oh my god yeah we've
always just gone really well for then
really when did you ever think he work
in your team yeah yeah so that worked
for me for about a year really yeah and
we just yeah we always got really well
like social sites that sites I to work
probably like not as much as we didn't
do now yeah I think that's what was
quite great about is we we we work
really well to each other because we
were quite different in the way we
approach different things okay where did
the conversation of you start method
also happen in the pub I'm sorry
restrictive governance parents just
there
it was sorry I left I left in May and I
was I was chatting to different
investors and yeah company in Bristol
made me an offer to go and join them but
I thought if I never am on our debt now
I'm never gonna write who is the best
person to come and join as a co-founder
and it was so big JC so we met for a met
for some granola
I think jatt was one of his healthy
health kicks an apple pie and a latte
and he said yeah we talked about it and
then yeah we just yeah plotted it and
you're so you're 18 months in yeah so
see happy to share the obviously but
you've been back to start that is that
all cool to talk a bit about that yeah
yeah yeah so I guess so 18 months in
first just to help for everyone listen
first 12 months you - yeah and then we
we had Cece who came were we think we
hired her in October as a resource er
yeah and then we hired a couple of other
people that probably a nova right well
yeah I suppose
taking responsibility was we probably
hired the wrong people and now we're up
to six with with two people joining in
January say cool so I guess let's just
talk a bit about the first 12 months -
you too how how how glad are you that
you've done it with each other if you go
I mean like not just just Tom on your
own how you put it pleased that you did
it yeah really there isn't anyone else I
don't think I would have gone into
business with yeah I think for me like I
knew that I had some areas that I needed
to work on yeah and I wanted to surround
myself with something that kind of could
give me those areas to work on Tom was
that person I worked really well
together
you know purse didn't get a chance to
like work as closely together but yeah
this is a good opportunity to fir know
selfishly for me to kind of you know
Bridger a couple of gaps from the skill
set level and the fact that like we're
pretty honest in my transplant of each
other we get on really well like
Tom's bit of morpheus reflector I'm a
bit more of like where my heart and my
Stephen gopher Gover things
but you know in the end we come to like
good mutual agreements yeah yeah pretty
much all decisions probably had like two
or three lovers Tiff's I stormed out the
office went to a client meeting nice
little Tom a bus stop no he just liked
each other give each other a hug right
what's going on you know and I could
tell chat was like give me some space
was like know what's going on it was get
over there and in hindsight exactly why
I shouldn't have done but yeah you have
a week off and you got all these ideas
what would have been some of the Kevin
thing about well-being some of the
benefits you'd understand over another
just having a sounding board and just
yeah
I'd to know like I can be quite hard on
myself and so can jack hard on himself
but actually we we kept things pretty
light for the first year I think it's
cuz we did so well I've got a phenomenal
first year and it couldn't have gone any
better really so we didn't really have
and so probably the end of our first
year anything negative to deal with
really so we had a pretty good first
turnover in the first year we did 1.2
million in our first year yeah not bad
that was not bad start yeah
and I'm Ben I'm gonna hand hands imma
kruta for about four years
mmm so literally picking up back on the
weight yeah it was weird but before you
know it but a not for an hour and I'm
offering my my second week for really
14k fear and the candidate can take it
convinced here's your site mate oh cool
cool this candidate I was just like it's
not going to take it he's like he's
gonna take care what any did or didn't
know we didn't take your mate was right
from anyway so yeah and as we were
talking about you start again and stuff
like that I think so couple of my
clients actually start their own
recruitment business being backed by
someone I think anyone listening that is
thinking about starting a recruitment
business will definitely think about
could I get something involved because
how someone else you jump start this
business or whatever I guess from your
experience being back to start your own
recruitment business yes firstly what
would you say have been the benefits of
hung that sort of relationship to
kickstart things how's that for me
personally I
I'd be really honest I didn't want to
lie in bed at night and you know know
that I had my house on the line again
yeah against the business I was big so I
just knew that wasn't good for me as a
person yeah so the way I'm the way I'm
wired and stuff so I think if anyone's
looking for investor like me as many of
them as you can you know need to you
know you don't need to pick any of them
but I think you can get a lot of insight
and pick someone that you get on with
yeah those questions if people do get
it's really don't think about yeah I
mean most high for most recruiters are
quite cynical on they because they're
like widest but you've got to find
someone you trust I think you know meet
and meet multiple times I beat him
socially I'd meet him in a work
environment yeah I meet informally
informally witches which is what I did
and I think the back we've got been
they've commit to everything we've we've
asked for and I think again I think you
need to try to find that balance between
a back of that wants to get involved but
also leaves you to do your own thing
hands off cycle you know we speak to our
backer once a month but we've made every
decision ourselves I think that's
anybody named Hart the people a bit
worried about know that they'd lose that
yeah would you would have been some of
the benefits for you Jack you think
thing like the benefits not for me
personally but as a company means
they're like we were able to grow a
contract book pretty much like from day
one yeah it's like if you lose solely
your own money
yeah the bankroll contractor and you
know some companies want 90-day payment
terms that you're not gonna pay a
contractor for 90 days so the benefit of
days is they you've got your contract
book which means that actually you can
kind of scale quicker so I think they're
like that's that's probably one of the
biggest assets for sure well the money I
had saved but I look to doing it I mean
that would have gone in about a month
really months oh yeah and why is that
them all of us you know you've got you
know again if you're doing contract
business which you want to talk like one
it's just it's just it's just a tional
yeah
cause yourself back so as you said know
them in the office you - yeah yeah in
your face no debt no one on the database
no nothing no well obviously just spoke
about your day plan but where the hell
do you where did you start
I can't say I basically rang everyone
I've ever worked with yeah outside my
restrictive governance period and I just
said listen I've set up I you know back
me you know just I went down the whole
knots all I feel sorry for me sort of
thing but you know back an underdog was
I back a start-up SEP Amaya work with
you years ago hmm
people I'd placed people I'd worked with
anyone that I knew who had a
relationship with me of some saw I was
just like work with me and Peter we
found that people I just you know got
involved in our journey and bought into
everything that we were trying to do
really yeah and it's been it's been
phenomenal really I'd had a relations
we've had I was like a rabbit in
headlights
because I doing like Tom like three
weeks I after yeah and he's there just
smashing through the phone calls like no
tomorrow wasn't really kind of winning
new business I was yeah no candidates no
nothing like Tom I literally got my
LinkedIn and just went through every
single person my LinkedIn who I worked
as a candidate as a client previously
and just like reached reached out to
them and just let them know that like
what was happening happy and yeah just
like talking the reasons why we were
setting out what they're like the
objective is people bought into the
story and yeah you know it what we found
is that actually a lot of people prefer
to work with like a smaller business
because they feel like the businesses
that you're given to you it's going to
be looked after and just having you know
another recruitment agency even with
like just any other yeah yeah did you
guys have a business plan you know a lot
of the investors I met were like you
know like you didn't don't ask me and if
everything goes out the window like sue
the earthy you yeah you mean I'm sure
get I'm sure people disagree but when
you're if you're if you're generating
business yourself right you something
you follow your nose don't
who came yeah we came across the client
the jacket worked with who we did
probably bout a hundred K with really we
had no idea that it was like week three
a week four hmm I had no idea that we'd
work with them so suddenly we started
doing this certain type of work really
really quickly so well I did we did like
a year forecast of what we want to do in
our first year yeah which we absolutely
smashed but I don't know we yeah we
didn't do not know this sort of market
who's gonna go for that yeah we knew
what yeah all of that stuff yeah but
Ryan the brand name is Tom's done like
bi data stuff let's go after that I've
done testing yeah like let's just give
ourselves the best chance of success and
just go after the two markets where
we've got the relationships you've got
the gang ladies you've got the networks
and go out and let's see how well we do
out here I'm really quickly we were
starting to bring on some like decent
business and it was almost like you
don't bite off too much more than what
you can chew yeah other clients are
going on can you help us on this can you
help us on this but like sometimes
you've got to say no to your very points
ago yes yes yes yes you lose your brand
you lose your other quality of the work
you're doing yeah like your brand by
loops really quickly and isn't a lot of
experiences myself
start my own thing now and light for me
obviously it was the first time I've
actually I'd say no and it was yeah it's
not like because when you work for
someone it's a bit more easier to say no
I feel like the same thing when it's
your own business a lot more orders and
why it's a bit weird yeah it's like
client clients will respect you more
though yeah totally yeah so would you go
back and do anything different do you
think system work yeah probably yeah
because we because we got off off the
ground so quickly but make you know
doing plenty placements is we probably
didn't register stuff like we should
have done yeah quickly as we we should
have which we addressed probably about a
month
sort of a or nine mmm I probably I don't
know like I don't I think maybe like the
way we like I know he spoke about it
earlier I think I was quite conscious
when when we spoke to people inside the
first thing to say talk how many heads
you've got now how many hires and got
and I think perhaps we just got drawn
into that right we've got a higher loads
of people yeah maybe we should have done
that a slightly different way but
julen would you have done if in
different jobs you think going back this
time uh no I I think like year one was
like a really good year first
yeah the learning curve is I've
certainly been year two will be doing
things different yeah we've had like a
few learning curves like one of them
being like don't hire purely based on
ability you've got higher based on like
culture fear with a blend of an ability
for sure yeah but like if someone's like
there's a few red flags rounds like
they're like the culture fit like don't
don't hire them yeah yeah that's
probably that's where the biggest like
once a we've those just to find the
lives out there and if I'm listening
right now and I'm online those first
three months done on my own what would
you say when you're having someone no no
if I'm listening right now yeah I'm
three months in to start mental
quickness what what we said to these
people concentrate on getting yourselves
go yeah yeah like we were thought I had
three months off work so I got the
website up and running that was done the
branding was all designed yeah we got
going but from day one just about about
sales cuz I think you can yeah you can
you don't have a business unless you're
generating cash did yeah
you can have the best culture in the
world you can have all this great stuff
around you know LinkedIn profile and
stuff ultimately if you've got no cash
growth to go through your business and
also your stress levels are a lot lower
when you're when you've got business
coming in hmm so I think that's that
would be my biggest piece of advice
because if labor going from making
certain angles I making sure you got
your day plans like like Tom would say
yeah plan the night before so when you
come in know exactly what you're doing
yeah I'm big believer on like mobile
mobile phone calls to hiring managers
like pre nine o'clock we stab like nine
before nine yeah it's all about just
like setting the pace on at home for the
day
if you're having like four or five good
conversations before nine o'clock like
that wave of like positivity and energy
they'll just continue throughout the
rest of the day yeah if you get in and
you're like you're pacing agency is sit
down grab a coffee
scroll through the news articles have a
little flick through Facebook like
you're not only like you're never going
make stars you might just have no
intensity and I just I have that
intensity like the entire day don't
really like to have like any long
but then at least when I get home I know
that I like what a good day we do if we
do have fun by the way yeah so so you
wonder it seems like we went pretty well
then yeah said but that was the learning
there then the whoring for your business
yeah if anyone's I'm sure lots of people
have gone through it if anyone's doing
it it's difficult because you wanna like
we were very conscious of not creating a
male orientated boy - smarter fun didn't
we didn't watch battery yes
our first hire we made sure it was a
girl yeah we wanted to do that straight
away to try and break the break down any
barriers you know our our office now is
it's not gonna collect ik we're like the
recruitment version The Inbetweeners
like we always refer to us we got real
different backgrounds we got like a real
different light everyone's so different
and that's unconscious really 100% Rena
and why have you done that because we we
didn't want it you see a lot of people
saying we want to change like change
recruitment stuff we don't want to do we
just make what I make fundamentally the
method and our approach to recruitment
the big slick as possible to make sure
if a client gives us a job I were done
but what we what we did were very were
very conscious of doing is making sure
we didn't have an environment where I
was just full of blood those little
Tom's yeah exactly we didn't we didn't
want that and you know it might take
slightly longer perhaps to to build that
environment you might you know kiss a
few frogs as they say base for
scalability you've got do that yeah do
that
my people buy from different people at
the end of the day like what works like
for me might not necessarily work for a
rich or for Nicola hmm I think gotta
have like a diverse like I guess like it
number of employee yeah I guess their
approach to doing business development
is gonna be no different from person to
yes and and we've had like you know
people that I've been trying to get in
with years four years the those guys
have coming got much lesser experienced
than me but they're just approaches a
little bit softer a little bit different
actually again they've had the
engagement that I have been trying to
get so how do you have you got there
for though because again it is a real
challenge I hear about all the time but
how are the both of you got better at
hiring bet obviously you're always prone
to making the wrong hire but what are
some of this or non-negotiables now
maybe that you look at people when
you're considering to join method or
you've got you've got you've got to be
able to enjoy their company I think
especially in a small environment is
that you know we've had scenarios
recently where we've been you know we've
met big billers that want to join us but
you know quite friendly they've not been
quite right for us and we've said no to
them yeah we've actually opted to hire
people that are you know far less
experienced but they're people that we
can enjoy and go out for a drink weird
working with other laughs weird and
stuff and I think that's my biggest
learn it's like you're spending 10 hour
11 hours a day with people you've got
got enjoy and go enjoy the compound yeah
yeah I think that like my friend Dan
Lewis he basically works with me a opus
went Australia and he set up like this
Australian office in the night in there
like they went from like two people to
now like hundred people over them like
four years so really like like I went to
him and I asked him for advice because
you know learn from that in the early
years ask for advice because we're
essentially doing a couple of things
wrong he said your first 10 people might
he was like you've got to be able to
take him for mine like if you don't if
you can't go for a moment then he's like
you don't hire him that my how good they
are really and I kindly took my own boy
I didn't like actually it's worked
pretty well just like really just like
taking that simple approach like you
can't go for a point with them or
socialize with them I don't ever hire
them and I think they will change that
as you scale yeah yeah right now many
like subcultures but certainly for like
the first like 10 hires there's a
nucleus in that life you really have a
solid 10 people that live and breathe
what you're about we want it to be then
they got like we know where are you no
matter like what makes a good manager
and stuff is that what I want to work
for me like if you're hiring these
people they've got they would have by
first he finds a method most importantly
but also binds us and jack as families
of the business so yeah you've got by
people that buy into you that you can
enjoy you know both work work and and
unsocial socializing with them as well
mmm and then what what's been your again
I know you we were talking about earlier
but sort of your view and having their
business is it's something that you've
both of you've known right it's just
honesty but we know you wanted to be
bigger than just
I do not mean like has it always been
something you've wanted to grow in and
get people involved in there we always
we refer to what the six now as the
original six really in an ideal
situation you know that in ten years
time the original six will still be here
like that might not happen you know yeah
you know anything could happen this is a
business that you want you want more
people involved yeah I've always been
the way that was that evolved in the
last 18 months do you think I'd like for
me personally and I think Tom's on the
same wave like I don't want it to be
like a two three in Japan yeah person
business no I Drive a have is like 20 25
maybe 30 Bert like everyone's performing
like the line is now and like when I
joined Opus we were like small like 30
40 people everyone was pretty much that
and they were the most enjoyable years
for me really I just wanted maybe like
recreate that but without skating it
beyond yeah but like who knows you know
is easy to say that and then next for
you know do um do you feel like you've
got a grasp of what like your culture I
was talking about this the other day
like you know I mean that's an
interesting one isn't anyone talks about
culture Burt do you do you feel like you
have a cult you've built I think I
wouldn't say we've got the finished
article yet at all but like you know
don't think you ever can yeah I think
culture quite culture evolves as now I
think we definitely got like we
definitely now with the with the
original six you know they work the
original six but then a six people that
we've got who I believe it we're gonna
build the business on and we've got a
wicked wicked culture they're they buy
into us let's face it they're not buying
into like this office didn't want
someone to join it for the reason
because we've got a nice swanky office
yeah sit it's interesting we had we had
an opportunity to do that but we made
the conscious decision to stay where we
are because we wanted people to come in
and if I owned to be like why this isn't
the great greatest but like like this
person joining method I can become a
good recruiter
yeah and that's fundamentally for us is
that you know if you join even work for
us we can teach you to be a good
recruiter you know we might not have you
know a ping-pong table or a dog or where
we have a robotic dog but you know we
might not have at the moment that you
know we would teach you to be a good
yeah if you've got people bought into
you guys and without the NASA absolutely
yeah yeah yeah
so last 18 months then I mean we were
speaking about downs and stuff yeah
let's talk about some of the channels
been pretty positive had a good first
year let's talk about cuz it's not all
roses know what's been some of the
biggest challenges for the bird for you
since starting this business going on
holiday leaving me have you have you had
much less hours working and running
method than I've ever worked less really
yeah
just cuz when you're in light is beaut
you're effective on you mmm hi I'm Holly
but how come Eva would be if you both
you how comfortable was you not being in
the business every debt you know I mean
how is that I was amazing house I'm by
pool in porch books - yeah yeah I mean
you're what you of course you're on your
phone since yeah but I think might not
hard to switch off like Jack put on your
phone like you know you gotta trust you
yeah you trust each other and stuff I
think for me that the hardest the
hardest thing I found it is is hiring
getting it right retaining your staff
yeah making sure everyone's happy I
think for me on a personal level it's
you know you look at your sales board
you've not got deals on there yeah you
need to put deals on there you need to
make sure you training your your new
starters you need to make sure they're
buying into method you've then got to
write your L&D program you know yeah
yeah and I think is the be move into our
second year the responsibilities then
Jack and I to make sure we're carving
our roles out in the right way to make
alright we've both had to be really
willing to do different things you're
aware that just got do what you've got
to do what you need to do I can think
about me and Thomas I Tom knows like my
strengths and my weaknesses in vice
versa we can kind of work off of that I
think they're like thing that sometimes
we're a bit privy to in which we're
still like on it on a learning curve is
like we're a bit two-faced down
sometimes we've just well you're out
doing a deal getting some money on the
board actually sometimes you need to
lift your head up and think okay what is
like the wider strike
the wider pitch area that we're trying
to achieve
like the rest will look after itself
yeah because you got to trust the
employees to do the activity whilst
means I'm focused on some of the other
stuff so that's his learning curve that
you know we'll go through at the moment
but then again just just I know we were
talking about this before the forecast
tomber I think just for people listening
who are early on my way you'll see you
were talking about you've got your block
quite grateful you've got quite a good
network of people that you can lean and
then have a bit of a sounding board like
how valuable is that being do you think
I haven't people do have so yeah really
I cruise you can be your friend and
friends with other recruiters isn't it
like there's this misconception that oh
yeah he's a recruiter I can take money
out of your pockets like you there are
lots of stops and Bristol that you know
we know of people that we spoken to
people from g2 and vivid that have
opened their own companies and run their
own offices I mean we everyone speaks to
each other my big simple call of light
I'm thinking of hiring this person is it
a good idea you give them a five minute
overview of what situation is and they
just give you that so I think anyone
listen like like be willing to sort of
reach out to people like you people
absolutely I just said earlier like
everyone we found everyone wants to
support startup and like help you with
your journey whether it's you know
branding or whether it's reaching out to
like an old trainer that you know used
to deal with a you know I debate to
Hanna about you before you even spoken
to you and all that kind of stuff even
once they help you out yeah how I'm
talking about a bit about challenges and
things like that
how will has since having your own
business how has it impacted your
personal relationships as you both I'm
on is it in recruitment yeah just your
personal nations your mates your
girlfriend's wife whatever light you not
me
like Friday like sounds really cliche
iji genuinely yeah like my kid's life
I'm at my happiest now okay than I've
ever been in the industry because like
we're in control of what we're doing and
I'm previous companies you know Billy
more money and make you more money but
you're at the mercy of other people yeah
yeah you can't continue no someone can
come in one day and go right we're doing
this we change the manual they all hang
on a second we're on the shop floor yeah
we're we're marshalling the troops no we
do it yeah and I think we are we're in
control of that and for me personally
the way I'm wired that is sooo like
important yeah so then better than some
of y'all see you have a young family so
like how's that been in terms of running
a business like you know you message
Jack and say I'm gonna be in at nine
o'clock mainly to drop you know Harry to
school or whatever it's like yeah no
worries or mmm because ultimately life
you know the old saying is it's like you
put into it we get out of it yeah that
is exactly it flowing where if we're not
representing method is the way we want
to represent it then our staff I'm gonna
do it mm-hmm
you know if they be if they need to go
and do things we let them do it
mmm you know it's I wouldn't say we're
promoting four day weeks or all that
kind of stuff on the moment anyway but
like you know we jack and i listen to
simon Sinek qualities autonomy purpose
and mastery at the three biggest
motivators for people and if we can give
people autonomy to entrust them to
master something and they've got a
purpose of why they're here then
hopefully they'll buy into that which
makes our life a lot easier really what
about you Jen because I think the reason
why I ask is because like again they'll
be real quickly to listening thing about
starting our own business and typically
the things that they may not think about
is the relationship with their partner
and how that's gonna be and stuff like
that you know yeah I don't know I'll
just for if I was underneath the Sun
really stressed me out
I generally work less hours and I've
ever done before
no Jim this next door go to the gym at
lunchtime you know it's like clears my
mind is actually what I do the best
thinking is actually in the gym at lunch
I then come back just refreshed revised
and then go again it's like just just
dividing out your day a little bit and
yeah we've been we've been quite
fortunate so far like I think as we get
bigger
I always find as a manager when your
team gets bigger you've got more things
to think about relatively small teams at
the moment so yeah there's business to
think about I think as we get bigger we
start trying to scale it I think that's
where it becomes there's more to think
about than isn't that hmm it's more like
plates to spin and mmm anything and then
sort of finalize this I guess anything
that you guys do now and a weekly or
just just now is quite habitual to you
to how you get through the tough times
and obviously cuz now it's on your boat
for your shoulders and if if anything
goes wrong that anything that you do
that it's good pub across the road penny
I think it's just really important about
how you set yourself up for the week's
always I've like Monday morning me first
thing I find out what businesses is
going on we can like uni construct that
like the things that are about to happen
for the week and like I think it's
really important just by lightly set up
for the week we have a catch-up on a
Wednesday see how Louise go in and a
catch-up on a Friday
so we can then plan know ahead so I
think that's like I have to know what
there's one as one thing actually it's
like which I wasn't very good at it's
like a like talk about like having a
business plan we now have a a long term
BD plan which is the RT TS stuff for
Jackson's like that's that's gonna
hopefully soundproof our business and
six to twelve months time which is a
long term business development plan
where we're holding these big events
that Jack's running yeah
that's hopefully gonna cement those big
term relationships yeah I think that's
something that for me I think is
certainly will same proof the business
moving forward and so obviously both
you've been a recruitment for a while as
we finish this then where where do you
see recruitment going where where is
this all going to think like for me like
recruitments changed a lot since like
yeah I thought I knew especially on the
technical recruitment side roles have
become a lot more technical recruiters
need to become a lot more technical yeah
I think if you need to survive to be a
good recruit so if you're doing IT
recruitment more specifically you need
to really understand like the discipline
that you're operating with video so like
one thing that like as Tom just like so
it's a touch upon it's like we had an
objective of setting up with method of
like being a recruitment business but
investing into like the technical
communities that were operating in
there's already a ton of like meetups
already happening so that's not copy
what other people already doing but I
identified those bit of like a spot in
the market to create a roundtable event
specifically engineered for kind of like
thought leaders and innovators in my
testing space yeah in a round table
format sort of bouncing the idea off a
couple of people I really respect and
trust in the market they were like love
the idea of that like I've been to a
couple of things similar but like
nothing the way that you described it
yeah sure so went ahead with that and
the first one two weeks ago partnered
with just the on it which is you know
one of our clients and yeah it was a
great event
yeah it wasn't your traditional
presentation one person talking for two
hours
we broke people down so if you don't
should like live in a room in your
market you have to yeah one person and
yeah like as Tom said like long term
like business strategy is to use that as
like your part of your longer term
proactive business development but yeah
like to anyone just know your market
like in terms of like your candidates
know your clients Nega tech and then
that will then give you like the
competitive advantage yeah the converse
advantage and like the respect of a lot
of people are you speaking with this
well mmm
what about you Tom where do you see real
quick moment you've been in the game for
a while yeah like Jack said it's
definitely definitely changed I think
there's way more tech around than has
ever been yeah and I think choosing the
right like tech platforms to work with a
partner with a super important mmm
but I think I ultimately for me like and
I'm a bit of a dinosaur with the sorts
of things you've got like you've got to
embrace all that new stuff you have to
do it otherwise gonna get left behind
but me it's like relationships just I
still favor Melanie Lyons we've got good
relationship with someone you can have
everything can change and you evolve and
you change what you're doing but if you
like a relationship and I think the me
that's the most important thing well
have been some of the just on that note
I remember quite a few people asked me
that's what's been some of the as you
said there's so much tech right now some
of this sort of best tech that you've
implemented in your business that are
quite good impact stick on LinkedIn I
thought yeah we've got two LinkedIn
recruiter lies
which for start-up is a reverse time a
lot of money in that but yeah you get a
lot of our candidates from from LinkedIn
yeah but it seems like and a tidy and
and various other bits and bobs we've
you sauce breaker as well which is which
is wicked yeah and what we what we've
got is is you know we run a every
quarter the guys get we invest a
percentage of our profit back into hell
Indian training yeah the guys want
that's a certain level it's a certain
piece of technology hmm and we can use
that kind of investment to bring it why
did you decide to I think that's such a
good idea when you're tell me about this
so one percent of your profit yeah
towards the people yeah I just I guess
like I we we wanted to hire people that
good at recruitment so we want people
that are trained well that have access
to the best tech like within reason
you're not gonna get bankrupt to do it
so we had the idea well every quarter if
you can invest percentage of your GP
into the revenue that the guys cray they
then go away and choose who they want to
bring in you and for that for whatever
reason it may be that that's why you're
here like the guys noticed you want to
LinkedIn chat we reached out to you we
were sat down and talked about right
what do we want to spend that money on
and obviously it was you so yeah well
done main as you finished them what are
you guys before I should have the last
question what you guys excited about
that you wanna shout about what's going
on in the method the world what we
started talking about it a little bit
with like the RTC outside the roundtable
yeah I it was it was such a like success
with the first one we're gonna be
running that every three months so
there's some continuity between like the
meetups that are happening people
actually wanted it to be happening on
monthly basis yeah fact is that it just
absorbs too much times on monthly basis
but you know it's a good additional bolt
ons of the services that were already
offering yeah and then we've replicated
that event for engineering leaders and
our data engineering leaders month so I
think they're like us it's like again
like that medium to long term business
development strategy is definitely kind
of doing that
and like I think it's just more about
like we've got a really strong team
they're really Sibley jr. at the moment
but like there's there some good people
cited by them home so what I'm excited
about is like getting every single one
of them and like not not just building
like a career but like a career where
they'll become like a future director in
the business where they can then start
to build their own teams and then we can
then me and Tom can retire and we're
also moving into a new office next week
which like for me some film Supercross I
think master this has been this has been
amazing here and like you know I like
the story of starting off in a you know
God back is gonna get annoyed by saying
it's a [ __ ] office in a smaller office
you know where there's nothing great
about it so we're moving it's a really
beautiful office in Clifton next next
Thursday hopefully that's a big yeah you
know we've got yeah we've gone we've
gone but I guess it gives us the ability
to scale which is a sign that like we
don't you know we don't want to just a
little small - you know again I think
being an environment where you feel like
you can't scale it definitely impacts
your decision man yeah you know I mean
yeah of course if you're making that
investment you like you know what
there's we can't definite scout and
growing this size business then that's
assertive like the point you made this
is an investment like this it's not it's
not for our egos it's an investment back
into the business so we reverse the
money fart money fell L&D for training
for the guys yeah and we're investing in
an office so we can give the guys a
better environment to work in and also
an opportunity to hire more people so so
you can again as does the team they like
if they see that we're moving into a new
office that they yeah part of our
journey they know that actually things
like we're not just full of hot air
we're not just promises that they're
never with delivering against it's like
we're promising things with delivering
against their
they'll then buy into us even more and
hopefully you know yeah they'll do more
deals in return more deals please yeah
final question before we finish weigh in
all right so basically you can answer
this question with a phrase or sentence
but the question is if you can if you
could communicate everything or crew out
there they take on an advice there
implement it oh no I know I'm gonna say
I don't know if it's the right thing or
not now mate you got to be honest what
do you say I know what you're gonna say
that's it again so if you could if you
could communicate to every single
recruiter out there and they'd listen to
Jack they're taking our advice and
implement it tomorrow what what what
comes to mind the phrase a sentence what
would you say to these people it's like
for them did I build a successful career
basically a complicated question mate
yeah would you say gone at Tom you start
one phrase this might go down bad they
go on pick up the phone pick up the
phone okay yeah like I was gonna say
that like in a few more words but yeah
like I odd mirror that is like to build
rillette like that is all about
relationships and that is for me fall
into the trap being the modern-day
recruiter we just relying solely on
email contact I've seen I've seen some
people actually be pretty good at it but
I get your limiting I said balance
between yeah I think they're like if you
want to be a really good recruiter you
need to put yourself into more of like
the thought leadership space longer term
and I otherwise like you always just be
kind of like an average recruiter that's
a long phrase I mean it's been a
pleasure
Koen key to